[musique]
ils ne nous laisseront pas entrer, nous ne nous laisserons pas rentrer à la maison
enregistré dans la région de Zaporozhye
Région de Kherson Melitopol
Région de Lougansk
Non, c'est déjà fini, tu sais
il n'y a rien nous sommes désespérés que devrions-nous faire
les clochards sont juste des clochards dont personne n'a besoin
personne ne fait attention à nous
veut une personne handicapée alors nous n'entrons pas
grimper à nouveau
[musique]
nous voulons rentrer à la maison avant qu'ils ne nous laissent déjà sortir
dit tout le monde est venu ici pour les enfants
Ils nous ont apporté tous les vêtements handicapés.
maintenant nous ne pouvons pas rentrer à la maison
juste des couches de médecine pour grand-mère
pas dans les toilettes, elle va sous elle-même, mais
est venu personnellement pour un accident de voiture
c'est notre gouvernement qui l'a permis, je suis venu
juste en Ukraine pour acheter des médicaments et
couches pour ma grand-mère